[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 comenzamos una nueva semana de
la mano de rosa pérez más de rosa qué
bueno saludar como todas las mañanas
aquí en directo américa vamos a abrir
entonces esta revista de prensa rosa con
una noticia destacada en el kiev post
dice lávrov aseguró que rusia no
pretende terminar la guerra ucraniana el
9 mayo esto recordemos que también se
hizo unas declaraciones de la defensa
británica y también otros organismos de
inteligencia perdón no defensa sino de
inteligencia buenos días raúl
exactamente no y es que ayer el ministro
de exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov vino
un poco a desmentir estas especulaciones
nuestras informaciones que como decías
avanzaron distintos servicios de
inteligencia o medios de comunicación el
ministro exterior de rusos dijo en una
entrevista en la televisión italiana en
un canal del grupo mediaset que
básicamente rusia no tenía prisa para
terminar esta invasión de ucrania el 9
de mayo que recordemos es el día de la
victoria en el que se conmemora en rusia
la derrota no la rendición del ejército
nazi frente al ejército soviético en
1945 básicamente lo que como decías
distintos analistas señalaban es que
rusia buscaría una victoria clave para
ese día a nivel simbólico sin embargo
lávrov dijo que el camino de la
operación está únicamente marcado por la
necesidad de minimizar los riesgos para
la población civil y para el ejército
ruso y eso es raúl en un contexto en que
han muerto pues cientos de civiles
ucranianos y que se investigan
potenciales crímenes de guerra
supuestamente a manos del ejército ruso
en ucrania no así es rosa y continuamos
con la invasión de rusia de rusa a
ucrania no la revista 'time' médica a su
próxima portada al presidente ucraniano
hablamos por supuesto de vuelo y mini
selenski con el artículo como lidera
zelinski que hay en este artículo es
revista 'time' rosa pues mira el
reportero de esta revista estadounidense
simon and schuster pasó dos semanas
dentro del complejo presidencial de kiev
al lado de selenski hay de su equipo que
vive y trabaja en estas instalaciones
este es un artículo muy grande y muy
largo pero destacamos algunos puntos y
es que por ejemplo no dice el periodista
que es él el que está en contacto
constante por mensajes por llamadas con
a las fuerzas ucranianas también que el
presidente ucraniano le explicó que en
las primeras horas de esta guerra el
ejército ruso estuvo a punto de
alcanzarle a él ya su familia en dos
intentos de asaltar el recinto
presidencial dice también selenski que
las fotos de losa de cadáveres muertos
bueno de los cadáveres lo que en abuya y
en cama torch pues todavía le persiguen
sobre todo por las noches no también
describe un poco el periodista como es
el sistema de seguridad en este pues
complejo que se ha ido relajando un poco
pues todo todo el sistema todas las
medidas mientras que las tropas de rusa
se han ido alejando un poco de la
capital no pero cuenta como las
contraseñas eran frases sin sentido que
cambiaban cada día por ejemplo explica
que es el esquí revisa todas las noches
su agenda sus tareas que tenía para ese
día dice a pesar de que la jornada ya
haya pasado siempre tengo la sensación
de que algo va mal también señala el
periodista que las tareas de excelentes
que de hecho tienen más relación muchas
veces en contar lo importante que es
esta guerra para para los aliados
occidentales que más que con la guerra
en sí también explica que el silenci ex
escribe gran parte de sus discursos no
de estos discursos que ha ido
pronunciando en los parlamentos de
alrededor del mundo también el
periodista señala que él conoció hacer
el esquí antes de que fuera presidente
cuando era actor y explica cómo ha
cambiado su carácter dice dos meses de
guerra lo han hecho más duro más
irascible y más acostumbrado al riesgo
pero su sentido del humor pues persiste
intacto y para terminar raúl uno de los
asesores de lenski que también era actor
le dice al periodista a veces selenski
se mete en el papel y comienza a hablar
como un actor que interpreta al
presidente no creo que esto nos ayude
nos ayuda sólo cuando está exhausto se
quita la máscara la máscara cuando está
cansado no puede actuar y solo puede
decir lo que piensa cuando es el mismo
es cuando causa una gran impresión como
él íntegro y humano que es y también se
les que le dice al periodista que aún
así con la retrospectiva de la guerra ni
por un momento se arrepiente de ser
presidente de ucrania increíble este
artículo y lo que dice no rosas y que
pues los que quieran ampliarlo por
supuesto ya saben dónde está en la
revista 'time' y pues también un poco
hablando sobre eso pues el humor en
estos tiempos no queda nada mal también
como un bálsamo no para todo el
sufrimiento que está viendo el pueblo
ucraniano para también darle ánimo y
recompró y reconfortar a su equipo rosa
cerramos con pegasus el programa
informático de espionaje que se detectó
en el teléfono móvil del presidente del
gobierno de españa y de la ministra
española de defensa como también lo
hablamos con esta corresponsal marina
colorado exactamente y hemos señalado
pues como lo como lo llevan tanto el
país como el diario punto desde españa
como el mont de francia y
particularmente nos fijamos en el
titular del país porque dice los
teléfonos de sánchez y robles la
ministra de defensa también han sido
espiados por pegasus y señalamos este
también porque tal y como nos contaban
marina esto lleva apenas dos semanas
después de que se conociera no el
espionaje con este programa en forma
israelí de más de 60 líderes sobre todo
vinculados con el independentismo
catalán y que esto supusiera una nueva
crisis entre barcelona y madrid y ese
espionaje la organización citizen lab
quien lo reveló pues lo digamos un poco
relacionado con la inteligencia española
y ahora se conoce pues como decía marina
que los teléfonos móviles tanto del
presidente del gobierno español como de
la ministra de defensa también han sido
pues espiados con este programa y
todavía no ha trascendido qué tipo de
información pues se extrajo de sus
celulares pero lo que queremos señalar
raúl es que si bien tuvo lugar este
espionaje en mayo y junio de 2021 y que
el gobierno español de momento no lo
atribuye a ningún ente como tal lo mont
sí que señala a marruecos pero
inicialmente y pues a los servicios
secretos de este reino que tiene pues
esta relación tan estratégica con españa
así es también como lo decía nuestra
corresponsal la marina colorado gracias
rosa entonces por toda la información de
esa revista de prensa nos vemos mañana
con más pasamos ahora su primer invitado
el día